hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for a
blind review of the six arc of black
clover being the witch's forest and holy
crap but
uh that certainly was something
especially towards the end where things
got wildly out of control and you know
what who would have thought that a
simple act of a witch getting a cat
would be so damn epic
amongst other things of course but
before we do this as per usual remember
to subscribe to the channel and like the
video to let me know if you want more of
the uh the black clovery stuff
i don't read comments out of your
spoilers but i do watch numbers
so feel free to make your desires known
that way now when it comes to the
premise of the witch's forest arc it
really is a bit more like two arcs
because we begin with a short story
featuring an invasion of the diamond
kingdom before switching gears into
finding a recovery option for asda in
the forest with that said it is obvious
why they're considered one arc because
there is a lot more connective tissue
between them than i initially thought
when going through them but there are a
couple of very important things to touch
on in this sort of prologue arc i guess
we'll call it the most prominent which
being a certain discussion that happened
between yami and william vanjins so like
everyone else currently reading the
series at this point the army suspects
that vengeance is almost certainly the
leader of the eye of the midnight sun
because
well yami has eyes but then came
something of an anti-climactic
revelation that vengeance is just
another guy who fell victim to the
common theme of this series being
discrimination he has this huge scar
zone on the top of his head he was the
illegitimate child of a noble and was
even considered cursed and he does go on
to have a rather touching flashback
involving the wizard king and with that
all should be good yeah i
don't think so this scene was so damn
strange admittedly this might be me
reading into things too much which can
happen but i really don't get why you
would create someone so deliberately
suspicious
just to dispel that suspicion
immediately plus there's this one panel
that really sticks in my mind where yami
says that vengeance isn't lying because
of ki
which is fine he doesn't need to be
lying about anything he said but that
doesn't mean he told the full truth
either and i really wonder what would
have happened if yami had just
asked him point blank are you the leader
of the eye of the midnight sun because
vanjian's quite cleverly danced around
that by bringing it up with the army
first you know that hole you suspect
that i might be the leader would that
be correct yami business well you know
maybe sneaky sneaky elves have ways of
getting around reading ki
because elves are a thing that exists
now which we only find out at the end of
the arc which we'll get to but for now
vengeance you are still suspicious af
but i do like your world tree magic it
was quite delightful and there's
actually a fair few other important
events
that happen within this prologue arc for
example we got to know gordon
slightly sort of and he basically has
fomo so i feel bad for him and i was
hoping we'd explore him a bit more
during this arc but we will save that
for later i guess
we also expanded our knowledge of the
diamond kingdom with their eight shining
generals three of which we saw here
being out of trash
although we did get to see lotus again
which was quite the highlight for me and
i love that in the very same chapter
where one of the shining generals said
that diamond soldiers have no word for
retreat lotus then immediately called a
retreat in the next page or so he's a
lot of fun and i wish that there was a
bit more of him here
also yuno was quite prominently featured
during this part which was nice because
he's clearly grown in our absence of him
and i really like that every step
forward astor takes is mirrored by yuno
on his own journey right down to the
idea that he's even developing his own
parallel harem to aster given that yuno
now has both silf and charmy after him
and as per usual the thing i loved most
was yuno once again proudly proclaiming
asta to be his rival i'm a very easy
person to please and it was very
heartwarming to see that panel if you
know genuinely smiling it's so much
better than the typical rival broody
crap but most surprisingly of all even
finral got some focus here interacting
with his brother langris
langris he infuriated me by the way
because langris is all like
a family shame the one who can barely
fight at all what business do you have
being on a battlefield and i'm just
sitting here being like
[ __ ] this guy just beat veto in the
last dark so you can well and truly f
off so i didn't quite realize how
attached i'd become to finral until this
very moment and in the end i'm just
continuously impressed at how tarbata is
expanding on the black balls and refuses
to waste any opportunity to do so
alright but now we need to talk about
the actual arc because the witch's
forest is quite
maddening so much hype so much intrigue
so much drama and so much of
one thing that i really really hate but
to start things off the whole reason why
we're delving into the witch's forest is
because of astor's injury sustained from
facing off against veto which was a
factor i quite liked it's always good to
have consequences especially when your
main character is a bit of a rash actor
and it was also quite touching to see
astor briefly struggle with another form
of adversity because even after being
told that he would never swing a sword
again astor just got right back into it
and decided to train his legs instead
because if something so minor as you
know losing two arms would have stopped
him then
he had no right declaring his desire to
become the wizard king in the first
place and in this arc i'd also like to
point out that astor is showing some
great signs of maturity as well because
there's one instance where he's facing
off against
fauna and he suggests that they sit down
and talk things out rather than fight
which is kind of odd for his brand of
character odd but nice
and then there's another moment against
large ross where he refuses to remove
his sword because he is not
a merciful [ __ ] i like it boy be
growing and he'll grow even more but
first let's talk about the witch's
forest
our main setting for this arc is pretty
stunningly drawn and introduces by far
the most terrifying character in the
series to this point in the witch queen
she is just out of this world on a whole
new level none of the midnight sun guys
have even come
close to the feeling of sinister that
this
like she's crying blood which works very
well with her blood creation magic
terrifying stuff there as well but i
think her design is actually strongest
in the moments where the queen gets
angry and basically becomes a shaded
silhouetted demonic thing where all you
can really see are her piercing eyes and
you know what she's probably my favorite
antagonist thus far and also responsible
for unlocking
two count him two major power-ups during
this arc the first of which is astor's
i don't know does this form have a name
but he has this moment of confronting
his literal inner demon for the first
time which
looks so damn cool i know that it's a
cliche to have the plucky youngstown and
protagonist saddled with this
overwhelming powerful and potentially
evil entity but i'm pretty on board with
this especially if it results in the
kind of fantastic art that we have of
this half or
partially demonic aster i really love
this design because you can see the
darkness infesting asta's body through
the relentless roots on his chest
attempting just to seep further and
further and the wing is a really nice
touch as well and i guess from here on
out the struggle is going to be not to
be overwhelmed by this force and i also
really liked the line from the witch
queen where she stated in your presence
all magic is meaningless that hit me
pretty powerfully but you know what else
became meaningless
this form because the true power up of
this arc comes in the form of the
destiny cat which speaking of vanessa is
a real star of the song i enjoyed
getting to know more about her her
connection with yami and seeing her
fight in the asta finral vanessa combo
again they are such a good team
but faced with the most desperate of
situations possible we see vanessa level
up and invoke the destiny cat which is
quite frankly the most overpowered thing
in the series thus far granted that the
cat can't actually be used very
effectively on its own it's still
incredibly ridiculous in fact it reminds
me of a jojo's bizarre adventure stand
called heya which is completely
powerless on its own but it brings its
user impossibly good luck and fortune
very similar to how this cat just
restructures destiny to favor vanessa's
desires so i do love the cat but i'm
hoping there's a drawback to it like how
costly it is with mana or whatever
because right now the black ball should
be unbeatable with this absurd ability
on their side alright though let's now
move to something that i really
really didn't like let's talk about zell
domina and
mariella i think their names are and as
far as my understanding goes these three
were introduced in a black clover novel
written by
someone else that tabata liked so much
he decided to put them in the actual
manga and while i think that's nice and
all this
was a bad decision i can't express just
how jarring it is to have three
characters turn up out of nowhere and be
intimately familiar with our main
characters it makes me feel like
i've missed an arc which i guess i sort
of did because i didn't read the novel
but it also makes me feel like i'm being
punished for not having sourced extended
media that i had no idea even existed
before this manga moment and here's the
thing if it was just a cameo or some
sort of other fun appearance it wouldn't
really bother me but the fact that these
characters especially
zell are so damn integral to this arc is
problematic problematic because i have
no connection to them whatsoever i read
about the events of the novel in their
mission report sections but i didn't
actually get to experience that with
them
so there is no connection there and it
really annoys me when massive things
happen like you know mars deciding to
betray the diamond kingdom all because
of a man who doesn't feel to me like he
actually belongs in the story so i do
appreciate what tabata was trying to do
but it does piss me off that to get a
full experience of the manga i'm
expected to have read another piece of
media but back to actual black clover
another massive section that i've barely
touched on is mars and fauna after ever
so long these two get reunited although
not in the most ideal of circumstances
and the midnight sun and diamond kingdom
conduct a very
conveniently timed dual assault on the
witch's forest which is our main action
piece of the ark and as it turns out
fauna survived somehow and was adopted
by licht which actually plays out very
similarly to asta's experience with the
end of the demon thing basically licked
off his final revenge in exchange for
the use of her body
just like the demon does with asta and
forbidden magic has been used to give
her this third eye thing which is
dispelled by mars and his sappy diamond
feels which is yeah it's pretty much how
we expected things to go but from this
moment on mars has been taken out of
antagonistic status and is a fully
fledged ally having had his romantic
moments with asta as many do and
deciding that his ultimate task will be
to turn the diamond kingdom into a
peaceful place which is slightly
unfortunate because it means that he had
to immediately leave fauna after their
reunion but now as for something of a
revelation we have the ever
knowledgeable witch queen telling us of
the existence of an elf tribe heavily
implying that our eye of the midnight
sun guys are elves or at least they're
leaders because fauna wasn't an
elf i think just someone being
controlled by the other forbidden magic
and there's also mention of an ancient
demon which well
scary i imagine that's the direction
we're heading into to re-summon that
with the power of rocks and things but
all in all this arc was really good
though i haven't even mentioned lardross
actually he was
he was there but speaking of something
very fun about the witches forest is
that the main antagonist was never
quite clear and arguably never present
you know at first it seemed like fauna
would be the main antagonist but then
changed into lardross and finally the
witch queen which was great because it
felt appropriately chaotic instead of
having this one grand focus and i really
do think this would have been my
favorite arc thus far
if not for the whole zell and friend
situation it bothers me
like a lot more than it probably should
but every time that zell domino or
mariella showed up the exact same
thought went through my mind which was
i don't know you i don't like you please
stop being so important in a story that
i am otherwise enjoying other than that
though absolutely brilliant arc and i'm
looking forward to reading more but that
pretty much does it for this blind
review of the witches forest arc and
what do you guys think please do leave
your thoughts in the comments below or
even join my discord server and if
you're keen for more black clover
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for very maybe
regular black glove of goodness
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time